[Música]
[Aplausos]
que alguna vez u otra
sentido la cne
el cielo y preguntarnos que hay más allá
los seres humanos son muy ingeniosos
hemos construido telescopios cada vez
con mayor amplitud mayor resolución y
mayor profundidad de lo que nuestros
ojos pueden ver naturalmente
en una ocasión muy especial en 1995
apuntamos uno de los telescopios más
poderosos a una región del cielo que
parece estar
desolada cerca de la constelación de la
osa mayor
durante 10 días consecutivos el
telescopio espacial hubble miró
fijamente este parche desolado en el
cielo
y la visión que nos dejó sigue siendo
una de las imágenes más sobrecogedoras
en la historia la humanidad
tras ese parche aparentemente solo en el
cielo se escondía un vasto universo
cósmico
cada pequeño
cada luz que vemos en esta fotografía es
una galaxia como nuestra propia vida
láctea con cientos de millones de
estrellas
ahora sabemos que probablemente existen
más de 100 mil millones de galaxias en
el universo visible y que probablemente
el universo se expande todavía más allá
de eso
quizá ahora está preguntando qué tiene
que ver esto con la inteligencia
artificial
en esta constante búsqueda por seguir
ampliando los horizontes de lo que
sabemos los seres humanos seguimos
desarrollando herramientas artificiales
y esta vez
estamos creando seres
inteligentes
inteligencias artificiales
sólo un poco a ciencia ficción
a pesar de que lo vemos cada vez más en
las noticias y en artículos y a veces
[Música]
bien áreas de la tecnología que nos
advierten sobre las amenazas que la
rodean
las posibilidades del desarrollo de la
inteligencia
la realidad es que la inteligencia
artificial
permea nuestra vida cotidiana
no hay más que hacer que tomar el
celular y utilizar prácticamente
cualquier aplicación por ejemplo que
utilice reconocimiento de voz
hace
unos cuantos años no más de cinco o seis
años
un problema muy difícil dentro del
desarrollo de la inteligencia artificial
lograr el reconocimiento de voz y ahora
es algo rudimentario la tecnología
y si esto es inteligencia artificial
naturalmente la pregunta es
que es en términos más generales que
otros cursos puede llegar a ser
los investigadores
que estudian la inteligencia artificial
les gusta una definición
muy
con cierta inteligencia
es básicamente la capacidad de tomar
información
y de utilizarla para resolver problemas
así es como nuestras mentes piensan
así es cómo
los grandes innovadores en la historia
y como cada uno de ustedes
ha logrado juntar ideas que parecían
estar desparramadas
y que los contaron en conceptos
maravillosos y nuevos
ahora la inteligencia artificial está
intentando resolver problemas cada día
más complejos como por ejemplo detectar
o prevenir enfermedades como el cáncer
actualmente también juega en los
mercados de intercambio de valores en la
bolsa y quizás más importante puede
terminar los libros the game of thrones
o sea que george martin todavía no ha
logrado hacer
otras
de las aplicaciones han llegado
a complejidades que van más allá de
simplemente estos ejemplos que acabo de
dar
e incluso han llegado
a superar la inteligencia humana en
algunos dominios
hace 20 años era impensable que una
computadora le pudiera ganar a una
persona en ajedrez
entonces llegó y bm
con deep blue y le ganó no solamente a
cualquier persona sino al campeón
reinante del mundo
gary kasparov en 1996
en 2017 y google con la computadora alfa
pudo entrenar a una inteligencia
artificial que en cuatro horas jugando
contra sí misma en múltiples partidas
paralelas
aprendió las reglas del ajedrez y no
solamente le ganó a cualquier persona
del mundo le ganó a la previa
inteligencia artificial reinante sobre
todos los otros campeones reinantes en
el mundo azul fecha
la pregunta es bueno
si ya la inteligencia tiene estos
dominios de inteligencia que van más
allá de lo humano
podría esto permear
a las artes las humanidades y en la
ciencia
la mayor los expertos creen que
podríamos ver
en los próximos 30 años
una super inteligencia artificial
que logré superarnos en cualquier
dominio posible arte su manera de
ciencia
y quizá otros dominios que todos lo
conocemos
por supuesto que no todos están
entusiasmados con esta idea
y hay muchos escépticos también
yo personalmente me inclino a aceptar de
forma más amigable estas predicciones
cuando volteé estaba en su lecho de
muerte llegó un cura y le dijo es un
momento para que renuncies al
algo que voltear le dijo padre este no
es el momento para hacer enemigos
no sabemos todavía
en dónde está
la respuesta
del progreso del inteligente oficial por
un lado tenemos
la posibilidad de la super inteligencia
poder aniquilar aniquilarlos podría
traernos nuevas soluciones a los
problemas que tenemos tu día
por otro lado podemos estancar el
desarrollo del inteligencia artificial
solamente es cuestión de tiempo para que
un asteroide o una guerra nuclear
totalmente prevenible o el calentamiento
global no se extinga
muy probablemente la solución se
encuentra en uno de estos dos extremos
en continuar con la inteligente inicial
o en un lugar en medio de estos extremos
y esto es algo que pongo a la
consideración de todos
para que reflexionen
yo personalmente quiero compartirles una
de las lecciones más importantes que me
ha dejado
el estudio de la inteligencia artificial
y este es arrogante creer que los seres
humanos nos sentamos cómodamente en la
cima
de la inteligencia
muy probablemente la inteligencia es un
espectro
que se extiende mucho más allá de lo que
no conocemos
así como el hubble nos llevó
a conocer los nuevos horizontes del
espacio la inteligencia artificial aún
nada nuestras mentes nos podría llevar a
conocer estos nuevos horizontes
creo que ahí es donde radica
la verdadera amenaza de la inteligencia
artificial
en sacudir nuestra posición privilegiada
como seres intelectuales en el universo
pero yo creo que esta amenaza es algo
bueno
ninguna escala de espacio o de
inteligencia debe definirnos ni como
especie ni como individuos
a medida que nuestros sueños y nuestras
realidades y nuestra significancia van
cambiando
es buena hora de deshacerse de nuestros
ideales percibidos
e inmutables sobre quién somos
todos los que estamos aquí presentes
todos los que estamos viendo en esta era
vamos a hacer parte de esta conversación
que va a redefinir nos
y que puede
plantear en que nos vamos a convertir
y quién sabe si tenemos suerte
en lugar de llevar nuestra visión de
aquí a allá
podríamos llevar nuestra mente de aquí a
allá a realidades que nos seguirán
maravillando
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]